i didn't leave my house i was living
with like three people in a house
didn't walk out my door for like
months i was too afraid to i would have
panic attacks every time i left
and one night i went to a 7-eleven at
three in the morning
because if i had to leave to get food or
money i would do it in the middle of the
night because i didn't want to be around
crowds
and i remember going to a 7-eleven just
to get something to eat and i drove up
into the parking lot
and i look in and there's one person in
there shopping
and i couldn't get out of my car until
they left the building are you serious i
was so i and then i was like
oh i have a huge [ __ ] problem and i
started crying i called sarah silverman
who i had met you know a few years
earlier
and she's like dude
this is
completely normal she goes
no it's not no she goes millions of
people oh yes
this is normal no everybody waits for
the last guy to leave the 7-eleven once
he's out you're that's good that's why
we all experienced that no but i don't
understand she goes you're having a
panic attack she's like that's normal
she goes
you need medication she's like i think
she's like do you see a therapist i go
yeah she's like you need medication
and
she gave me the name of her doctor
and
took everything i had to drive in the
middle of the day to an office in
century city
and sit in there and talk to this woman
she prescribed me lexapro
and i started taking lexapro
a little tired for a few days but within
two weeks i was like
back going out doing stand-up changed
your life changed my life
this was like 2002 or two are you still
on lexapro yeah
spitting on it since then if it ain't
broke
don't fix it i i it's working so you
really don't get depressed all that much
i mean we all get depressed normal
depressed like you know i'll get sad but
she didn't give you anything for the
anxiety she gave you things for the
depression
lexapro is it's both it's for anxiety
disorder it is and depression okay i've
never taken that one yeah it's good wow
so so sarah silverman got you saved my
life saved your life you also did a show
with career-wise and
emotionally career-wise why did you why
did sarah silverman save your career
after i had quit
after i quit reality shu tv i didn't
know what to do i didn't want to go back
to working in a coffee shop
um
sarah and i had gotten on medication
sarah called me one day and said jimmy
she was dating jimmy kimmel at the time
she's like jimmy's doing
a talk show now
she goes they they don't even have a
name for this position but they need
someone to do research
to just watch tv and find funny clips
from to make fun of in the monologue
i was like i'll take that
i'll sit in an office and watch tv for
10 hours a day so i did that
that was kind of miserable just because
you're watching
you're watching the view you're watching
uh the 700 club tv you wouldn't watch if
yes you're looking for funny things to
make fun of you know uh
um
you know home shopping network stuff
like that right
that's what i was doing it was driving
me crazy i couldn't watch tv when i got
home at night because i just didn't want
to
but i stuck around because i wanted to
be a writer i was like i think i can be
a writer
and
i let jimmy know and
as soon as there was an opening like he
made me a writer like he was the best
wow